you're willing to stand out here and on
a winter's day for an outdoor lobster
Roman absolutely you have a line of
about a hundred people waiting in
30-degree weather to buy a lobster roll
for like 15 or 18 dollars obviously
there's a sort of a masochistic streak
amongst foodies DCD regulated to some
extent in 2007 and that's allowed trucks
like Red Hook to propagate around the
city across the square there's a pizza
truck there our cupcake trucks there's a
really really good Korean taco truck how
much stuff are you gonna buy at the
lobster truck ten lobster rolls and a
couple of clam chowder's so are you
bringing stuff back for your co-workers
if you sprinkle old bay spice in it
sighs can you stop a lobster dead in its
tracks probably a lot of regular
restaurants in DC are bothered by mobile
trucks does it bother you nope which
Washington bureaucrat looks the most
like a lobster maybe Henry Waxman
do you like the mayonnaise or the butter
mayonnaise butter butter butter butter
is better
I think I might get one of each the
lobster rolls cost I like 15 bucks is
that a stretch for lunch
I think frankly there would be a revolt
at the City Council is to try and crack
down on lobster trucks and other roving
food trucks in DC